philippe laurent bonjour merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur arte france le
conseil d'état a donc rejeté un votre
arrêté qui rendait le port du masque
obligatoire comment est ce que vous
comprenez cette décision d'abord le
procès d'état naturellement n'a pas jugé
sur l'opportunité même de la mesure qui
consisterait à pour enrayer mieux
d'épidémie généralisée le plan de
protection et même s'il n'a pas parlé
il a simplement enfin simplement si je
puis dire il a dit que finalement les
pouvoirs des maires en matière de police
de police générale des maires et est
donc restreint voire pratiquement
réduite à zéro lorsqu'il y avait une loi
d'urgence sanitaire comme c'est le cas
actuellement
alors ça pose de nombreuses difficultés
parce que ça remet en question quand
même tout l'équilibré en fait des
pouvoirs entre l'état et les maires et
met le doute que cette décision sera
gâté qu'elle va donner lieu à des
multiples controverses dans les jours
qui viennent alors les maires ne peuvent
donc plus prendre de mesures autres que
celles prises par l'état sauf raisons
impérieuses
est-ce que vous estimiez qu'il y avait
une raison impérieuse assauts tout à
fait d'ailleurs à socom le cas échéant
dans d'autres communes parce que il se
trouve que aso il y à une concentration
très forte de commerce alimentaire dans
un espace très étroit très petit et que
par conséquent même si les gens sortent
un peu moins que d'habitude je dis
simplement un peu moi eh bien ils
sortent quand même et il se concentre
dans un endroit donc très étroit et se
côtoient c'est la raison pour laquelle
j'ai jugé nécessaire pour préserver les
maires et pardon préserver des habitants
que les chacun préserve les habitants
qui en face de lui
j'ai jugé nécessaire donc de prendre cet
arrêté le 6 avril j'avais constaté
d'ailleurs en week-end du 4 avril à
relâchement très nette et confinement
autant plus le premier ministre avait
déjà évoqué cette semaine dans la
semaine précédant le déconfinement alors
niro - on le sait on sait tout le monde
ne peut pas se procurer un masque
aujourd'hui par conséquent le port du
masque obligatoire n'est
il pas une restriction finalement de
liberté à ceux qui n'ont pas qu'ils ne
peuvent pas en avoir alors pas du tout
parce que dans mon arrêté je ne
prescrivent est pas le port damageux
prescrivait le port d'une protection
quelle qu'elle soit qui avait pour
objectif d'empêcher ou en tout cas de
freiner les missions de postillons par
par la personne qui est forte cette
protection dont il s'agissait pas du
tout donc déjà un apport de masse mais
accorde une protection ce qui n'est pas
du tout la même chose mais je veux
souligner que la décision que j'avais
prise de froid de cet arrêté et est
incluse dans une démarche beaucoup plus
globale qui consistait à avoir déjà
lancé des fabrications artisanales donc
de masques là pour le coup avec est
assis et c'est pour une grande part tf1
une bonne partie de la population nous
avons fabriqué plusieurs centaines déjà
et est livré plusieurs centaines à des
habitants surtout des personnes fragiles
et âgés et nous aurons à la fin de la
semaine prochaine est livraison de 30
mille masque en tissu réutilisables
il ya vingt mille habitants assauts donc
c'est à dire plus à masquer par personne
trente mille masques et réutilisable qui
seront distribués dès le 30 avril je
l'espère en tout cas des 30 avril à
l'ensemble de la population de sault
donc que j'étais dans une démarche est
globale
moi je considère que si vous voulez la
raison impérieuse et c'était très
simplement très simplement de sauver des
vies il me semble que c'était une raison
quand même après rieuse alors vous le
disiez à tous les maires de france sont
maintenant concernées est ce que l'on
peut craindre une baisse des initiatives
locales justement dans la tente d'
instructions du gouvernement
en tout cas vous est ce que maintenant
vous allez attendre les instructions du
gouvernement où finalement vous allez
aller au delà de la décision du conseil
d'état avait généré évidemment pas
contre la décision du conseil d'état ça
veut dire comment l'arrêter n'est plus
une étude n'est plus applicable
naturellement mais comme je vous le
disais dans ce qui concerne la
protection la population nous
continuerons évidemment à l'ouvré pour
fournir le plus possible les plus
rapidement possible donc c'est ces
masques à l'ensemble des habitants
je pense qu'on arrivera encore une fois
très nettement avant l'état d'ailleurs
est par ailleurs par ailleurs s'agissant
de déconfinement j'attendrai en effet
des instructions très précises de l'état
pour savoir ce qu'il convient de faire
dans les écoles des crèches des centres
de loisirs
et je dois pour je vais pas vous dire je
suis extrêmement pessimiste quant à la
réussite de ce déconfinement si les
maires sont totalement privés des
initiatives comme c'est malheureusement
le cas à l'heure actuelle pour conclure
en quelques mots plus généralement
comment est ce que vous observez les
mesures prises par le gouvernement ces
derniers jours je les observe avec
inquiétude car je pense que ces mesures
ne sont pas suffisantes
je pense que dès le départ il fallait
donc demandé à chacune et à chacun de se
protéger d éviter au maximum des maîtres
donc ce fameux nuage des postillons dont
on sait qu'il est le vecteur privilégié
de transmission du virus
ça c'est la première chose je pense que
c'était une erreur majeure de dire dès
le début que le port d'un masque était
inutile est vraiment une erreur majeure
je comprends pour bella ça a été fait
parce qu'il n'avait pas suffisamment de
masques industriels pour être distribués
à la population en même temps qu aux
soignants et un après vie des soignants
aient eu raison mais il fallait pas dire
que le masque était né il fallait dire
on en a pas assez
on va en fabriquer en faire fabriquer
etc mais en tout cas en attendant
protégez vous y compris avec un masque
artisanales comme celui qui est sur
l'image date est il qu'ils aient sur
votre écran et donc il fallait vraiment
faire cela je trouve que là c était une
erreur
presque une faute qui a probablement été
un certain nombre de personnes
contaminées en plus et qui a provoqué
donc à 52 morts supplémentaires merci
et c'est là où je suis je suis stupéfait
si vous voulez de l'altitude
non pas des conseillers d'état
finalement met surtout en avant merci
beaucoup philippe laurent d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes le maire udi de la commune de
souffle